one of the things that's quite
interesting about the gulag camps and
this is something that's very relevant
to understanding of modern Russia is
that so ordinary criminals were put into
the camps and so we're political
prisoners prisoners but the ordinary
criminals is so those would be rapists
and murderers let's say as well as
thieves who were engaged in theft as an
occupation those were regarded by the
Soviets as socially friendly element and
the reason for that was that they
assumed that the reason that these
people had turned to crime was because
the applause of the oppressive nature of
the previous Czarist / capitalist system
and that the only reason that these
criminals existed was because they had
been oppressed they were oppressed
victims of that system and so one of the
convenient consequences of that
absolutely insane doctrine was that the
Soviets put the ordinary criminals in
charge of the camps and these were very
very seriously bad people and so you can
imagine the way that they treated the
political prisoners who were regarded as
socially hostile ailments sometimes
because of their own hypothetically
traitorous acts but more often merely as
a consequence of their racial or ethnic
identity or the fact that they were
related by birth to say people who had
been successful under the previous
system so who had any any association
with nobility or any association with
what we're known as the kulaks who were
the only successful class of former
peasants in the Soviet Union because
they were regarded as privileged you may
have heard that word more recently they
were regarded as privileged and
therefore as enemies of the state and it
didn't matter if it was your father or
your grandfather or your
great-grandfather who happened to be
privileged but the mere fact that you
were a member of that group with
sufficient reason to put you into a camp
and we're talking hundreds of thousands
or perhaps millions of people who
underwent that fate and so the idea in
the Soviet Union was just because you
were the member of a class even as a
consequence of your familial association
you were immediately sufficiently guilty
to be put into a camp and punished in
the end the terms for the camps were
often 10 years 15 years long and if you
were very fortunate you've got to have
two or three of those so the the Soviets
really instant implemented end and
affected the idea of class and ethnicity
based guilt it's a very bad road to walk
down and it's something that we're very
much engaged in at the moment because
there's discussion everywhere in North
America now about the idea of well race
predicated guilt for example an ethnic
predicated guilt and it's a very bad
idea to classify an entire group of
people as guilty of anything based on
their group membership so these these
sorts of things are things we haven't
yet learned and certainly should have